Remember when we thought
the pandemic was over?
We did it!
The pandemic is like a TV show
you thought was canceled,
and then it got picked up by Netflix.
If a man calls another man crazy,
it's a compliment.
But if I was like,
"This is my wife Jeannie, she's crazy."
I even get nervous saying that.
My wife was like, "I wanna go to Hawaii,
and I wanna bring the kids."
And I was like, "Whose kids?"
My one goal was to just not burn.
'Cause you see a kid with a sunburn,
you're like, "Parenting's hard."
You see an adult with a sunburn,
you're like, "That's an alcoholic."
I almost feel sorry
for the accountants of the billionaires.
'Cause you know they were like,
"You had an amazing year.
You made 40 billion dollars.
But I fudged the numbers
so it looks like you broke even.
As long as you lay low
and don't draw attention,
we should be fine.
You got anything coming up?"
"I built a rocket...
to fly to outer space.
Does it matter if the rocket's
shaped like a penis?"